hey guys I'm Ryan right hello then
Veronica success we're tryna act like we
didn't have sex just now but we totally
did and it was awesome and we're also
gonna pretend that we did get in a big
argument right now yeah
which led to some great sex we're gonna
watch it you're gonna taper the Piron
it's a horror movie I figured we start
the night with horror because you don't
like horror I get the reaction of me
yeah exactly and that's what people love
about this show are the reactions right
that's like it's a trailer relationship
sweating dude do you see that you look
at that oh just drop a sweat just fell
on my arm I'm proud of that I slept like
a man but suffice as Kevin had it has
been closed the curse of the Pharaohs
engines against adventurers who disturb
the sacred teams of the pyramids 1690
nothing people polish ship carrying two
mummies is haunted by spectral visions
and brutal stones
15:03 for expedition members hinder
khafre's pyramid never to emerge 1922
Tutankhamun's tomb is opened and a
series of horrifying deaths befall the
excavation team for the next 90 years no
other tombs are disturbed
ah so what happens here usually found in
the caves two structures in the pyramid
cool don't touch anything
little does his carpet still have story
this is a warning
don't you want to get the [ __ ] out of
there so that built the purpose of
keeping whatever is inside from escaping
check out super [ __ ] up version of the
mummy I was thinking the mummy at first
but then I started what is that new
silver look all right before except now
it's in a pyramid but it's always
historical monuments but here's what I
will give it is I feel like people after
so much cinema feel like there might be
more familiar with pyramids and they
would a catacomb so to see this stuff
happening in a pyramid
might seem more plausible as an argument
I might make to play devil's advocate on
this one but I'm not looking for a fight
but I was gonna say something I was
gonna sound really intelligent saying it
and then he interrupted me and now it's
gone what the [ __ ] Ryan what the [ __ ] no
I don't like interrupting you especially
you know when you're saying certain
things during certain things intelligent
things I guess that are intelligent they
sure make me feel good yeah I mean it
looks scary
it doesn't look terrifying it looks like
okay yeah it's a good setup it sounds
good on paper as far as execution goes
it looks a little bit like been here
done that before so especially once they
get into the dark yeah it's just not a
closet phobia you can't see what's going
on people screaming yeah and the trailer
hole I mean there's always that with
someone being like attacked it's like a
quick attack like that Super Smash
Brothers or something you're thinking so
you don't know I'm talking about
Semillon Mario and starfox oh yeah do
you eat eat eat eat eat eat eat eat eat
that one Mario and the princess know
you're adorable
what you said Mario and then star or
something no that's the second you just
named like every Mario game ever I
wasn't old enough as a kid you talking
about it's like a new Mario game every
couple years well I don't know that it's
online I was like Nintendo and Tendo 64
like the original thing well you know it
wouldn't work so you had to blow on it
and then it always made it work
sometimes the way that's the way I work
so I think you should sometimes treat me
like I'm an intended cartridge you know
when I accept that you just said that
because I gave it to you it served it to
you I know good couples section
in Section C people thought the Nottie
would stop but no getting amplified oh
yeah because you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
yeah it's a good channel check it out
and Veronica 6 to us as a channel 2
there's music and blogs other [ __ ] she
does too and it's pretty cool I enjoyed
the channel she's almost at a thousand
it's awesome Wow there's almost a comma
in your subscriber is it now you just
said my mouth is getting worse and worse
what does that mean to these people
Antonio Corona Ryan can I get a
shout-out please man okay Antonio Corona
he asked us on our Robin Williams video
where you look like a baby the whole
time just a weeping willow is what you
were yeah
like a real man I've had to comfort you
I have to tell you to chin up
thank you for that very very being
strong and and I thought very highly of
you in that moment thank you and Antonio
Corona clearly felt the same way about
me
so yes you are gonna give a shout out my
friend respect the dick you said you
think that Trevor Smith I've been been
watching all the episodes from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia trying to
get a well-earned shout out ha ha a few
days later holy [ __ ] I just found the
episode and you look so [ __ ]
different and he lists that episode I'm
not gonna tell you which one that is
but he caught me on It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia fabulous I was also on an
episode of unfabulous Nickelodeon show
hammer Roberts horse nose you know I'm
documenting looks like a horse she was
on Wizards of Waverly Place reoccurring
role series no Zoey 101 Zoey 101 Ned's
Declassified I did a Spanish GMC
commercial she was part of that one too
did the soccer one commercial
anyway Trevor we're trying to give you a
lot to look for right now so find all
those things that's the footage cuz we
don't have it so that would be really
nice if you were able to do that for us
Aidan Nexus can you give me a shout out
yes Aidan Nexus you can totally have a
shout out Nexus is sounds like well you
know I'm going with this genitalia how
they're gonna say sexist sexist it could
be a sexist Nexus Nexus Nexus sexist ah
you know what it might be that because
it rhymes right mm-hmm
you could trust any image for rhymes
chances are that's the thing makes this
a stunt [ __ ] concert stunts sometimes
you get it you know what's a stunt
well you know stuff like I stunt like
you fly through the air and land on your
hands yeah that is the definition of a
stunt Aidan Nexus
look man I hate names that I don't
understand that meaning to and there
should be a parenthesis next to them so
I couldn't be like oh I get it now makes
sense but he doesn't make any sense
wait I thought
sieze I've been saying you're wrong this
whole time I thought parentheses I don't
think we'll ever learn going back and
forth on it you have to look it up yeah
no it's this way because I've been
saying it this way no one's corrected me
yet anyway next is eating give me much
to work off